je voudrais simplement vous rappeler que
le référendum le référendum est un outil
un outil démocratique qui permet de
trancher dans un moment de doute un
certain nombre de questions et il me
semble que nous sommes au cœur de ce
doute et je pense donc que le référendum
est nécessaire alors bien évidemment il
y a des réticences du président de la
République il y a des réticences du
gouvernement pour convoquer un
référendum mais je dois dire que ça ne
m'étonne guère car ce qu'il craignent et
un peu ce que craignent aussi nos
collègues de la majorité sénatoriale ce
qu'il craigne c'est une remise en cause
de leur légitimité or ce n'est pas le
sujet ce n'est pas du tout le sujet et
si Monsieur Macron se félicite et cela a
été dit du bon sens des Français il doit
aller donc au bout de sa logique et
favoriser l'expression de ce bon sens et
non la crainte je pense que rejeter
cette motion s'est envoyé un message
très pas mauvais au 90% d'actifs et aux
soins plus de 60% de Français qui
veulent le retrait de ce texte parmi
lesquels je voudrais insister parmi
lesquels des électrices et des électeurs
de Macron au premier tour de la
présidentielle mais aussi des électrices
et des électeurs qui soutiennent et ont
voté pour les candidats des candidates
de la droite qu'elle soit LR ou sans
triste aux dernières élections on peut
s'interroger sur leur niveau de
tolérance de ces électricités sélecteurs
car cette réforme vient compléter des
contraintes financières et sociales qui
leur sont imposés depuis plusieurs
années maintenant donc la colère est là
le ressentiment est là il serait temps
que vous sortiez de votre bulle pour
entendre non seulement les flatteurs
mais surtout en temps de celles et ceux
qui
exigent pardon le retrait de ce texte
pour notre part et nous en sommes
signataires nous soutenons cette notion
référendaire
[Musique]